pendant que les matchs ont lieu au
palais des sports
non loin de là dans le parc pasteur on
tape aussi la balle des jeunes joueurs
de tennis de clubs voisins échanges avec
les pros qui veulent bien se plier au
jeu stéphane robert l'enfant du pays est
l'un d'entre eux je suis du loiret je
suis du montargois mais l'orléanais
aussi je connais bien j'ai été étudiant
ici j'ai fait pas mal de fois le tournoi
aussi donc c'est toujours un plaisir je
sais que c'est agréable pour les enfants
de jouer avec avec des joueurs
professionnels avec des joueurs français
et encore plus avec moi qui suis du coin
donc ça leur fait plaisir et moi ça fait
plaisir aussi du plaisir donc c'est le
mot d'ordre de ce qui est dit est
organisé par élise elle est chargée de
trouver une dizaine de joueurs pour
taper des balles avec près de 200
enfants
allez on y va les emplois sinon vous
allez mettre en beauté les gonfle après
c'est un réel plaisir de jouer avec un
joueur professionnel qu'on le connaisse
ou pas parce que forcément il ya des
gens qui sont moins connus que d'autres
mais je pense que c'est toujours une
expérience pour eux de vivre ça leur
coach donc à l'année l année se prépare
aussi un petit peu à cet événement et
puis ça permet nous aussi avec les clubs
de créer de tisser des liens tout
simplement
kenny de schepper 193e mondial du haut
de ses deux mètres répond lui aussi
volontiers à l'appel et espère susciter
quelques vocations
je sais pas s'ils pensent qu'à ça mais
en tout cas où
oui sur le moment ils sont ils ont envie
de jouer quoi donc
après je sais pas je connais pas leur
vie mais c'était prenant 1 2 qui qui va
réussir un jour mais on sait pas
vraiment tout cas c'est d'avoir du
plaisir sur moment et ça marche
la plupart des enfants y trouvent du
plaisir
ils arrivent avec des étoiles plein les
yeux et pas le pro il le trouve grand
musclé il tape fort
voilà enfin un prêt regarde et surtout
après sur les matches il regarde
vraiment il s'intéresse à la technique
vérifiez un peu ce qu'on leur dise ici
je retrouve chez les pros tout ce qu'on
peut leur donner comme correctifs au
long de l'année ça nous devons souvent
est vraiment en plus ça crée aussi une
bonne cohésion club de faire cette
sortie la cité bien enfin si une bonne
expérience j'ai joué avec un genre trop
basse et agréable parce que ma déjà il
gens qui jouent bien avec nous et puis
ils nous envoient au liban comme on veut
et puis voilà ça fait plaisir
voilà c'est un bon moment il savait pas
si ça allait marcher
je me disais que j'avais peut-être ma
chance et au final va 18 ans plus tard
je joue encore une fois les balles
échangées et les autographes signées
place au match histoire de voir en
pratique des bons conseils donnés par
les plongeurs les enfants repartiront
ensuite avec des rêves de tennis plein
la tête
[Applaudissements]